when the unclean Spirit has gone out of
a person it passes through waterless
places there's a reason why I want you
to emphasize waterless Places You'll see
but keep going uh then it says I will
return to my house from which I came and
when it comes it finds the house empty
swept and put in order then it goes and
brings with it seven other Spirits more
evil than itself and they enter and
dwell there and the last state of that
person is worse than the first so also
it will be with it also will it be with
this evil generation Okay now what's the
house that the unclean Spirit left oh a
person a person how do we know the house
he left is a person uh it says in 43
what did it say again uh when the
unclean Spirit has gone out of a person
there you go so the house that he left
that he wants to go back to you're told
in 43 is the person that he left right
ah yeah okay are you making the
connection yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
go number
one God calls you a house to be
inhabited human beings individually
collectively you as a person were
created to be inhabited to have someone
live in you it's number one if you don't
have God's spirit living in you you're
going to have an unclean Spirit working
in and through you picking up occupancy
residency in your body because your body
is a house someone has to live in it if
it's not God living in you and working
through you and occupying your body as
his physical vehicle then an unclean
spirit will yeah gotcha I understand did
you catch it now yeah yeah yeah yeah
thank you okay so what did Jesus mean
when it says the unclean
Spirit goes looking for waterless places
did you catch the second thing
waterless places meaning it looks for
arid desert land to dwell in right yeah
it cannot and will not dwell in watery
places right would that be those that
are baptized yes and not only baptized
but water represents Holy Spirit go to
John 7
38-39 yeah whoever believes in me as the
scripture has said out of his heart will
flow rivers of Living Water now this he
said about the spirit whom those he
believed in him were to receive for as
yet the spirit had not been given
because Jesus was not yet glorified okay
did you catch it what does the river of
Water of Life Of Living Waters refer to
the spirit those who have the Holy
Spirit living in them flowing in them
dwelling in them right yeah yeah yeah of
course that okay did you catch that can
everyone else are you learning the
meaning of Matthew 12:43 to 45 when an
unclean Spirit leaves a person it goes
looking for waterless arid dry places
meaning humans who are spiritually dry
humans who are devoid of the river of
Living Waters humans who are not born of
the spirit who do not have the Holy
Spirit indwelling them what you're
learning here is that demons look for
unoccupied homes individuals who don't
have the Holy Spirit of God living in
them so they look for waterless dry Aid
places so then that's the second point
that you need to focus on understand and
meditate the Lord is teaching you you
are a home as someone who's a home
someone has to occupy you someone has to
live in you that someone preferably is
God because God created your body to be
his Temple not the Temple of someone
else but if you don't turn to Christ and
you don't you're not baptized in Christ
and you don't have the spirit indwelling
you then someone else will be living in
you in other words what Jesus is saying
there are no neutrals either God
occupies your house your body or unclean
spirits do okay so that's two things you
learn right there your body is someone's
Temple someone's home correct
yeah yeah yeah yeah I fully understand
that thank you now when the Lord says
that that unclean Spirit decided to go
back to the
house that he was cast out of he found
the house swept why because the unclean
Spirit had been cast out correct yeah
however it was still
unoccupied no one was living in it so it
was swept and kemped meaning that
individual no longer had a demon
demonizing him and oppressing him
because the demon had been cast out of
him but he was still unoccupied he still
had a vacancy so now the unclean Spirit
saw an advantage not only is the house
empty so I can take
residence in it but I can bring my
buddies who are even more wicked than me
more evil than me so you learn a third
fact in the Demonic realm there are some
demons more powerful more wicked more
vicious than others
did you learn that yeah yeah he brought
seven unclean spirits that were
what in Matthew
12434 that more more evil than the first
so did you catch it yeah you understand
that the Lord just confirmed in the
Demonic realm some demons are more evil
more nasty more vicious more wicked than
others they're all evil but some are
more evil than others some are more
powerful than other demons so even in
the Demonic realm there are demons who
fear other demons because they're more
wicked and evil than they
are it's amazing now you can get so much
from three verses exactly because the
Bible is an
ocean that you cannot plunge the depth
because it's the revelation of the mind
and will and word of God and God's word
is an ocean that you need to constantly
Plumb the depths of by the power of the
Holy Spirit Illuminating you so you
learned that too right yeah yeah yeah
yeah the final thing you learn that you
cannot be
vacant and if someone is demonized and
yet that demon has been cast out here
she better get right with God and allow
the Holy Spirit to fill him and to
indwell him because when the spirit
lives in you demons cannot touch you
however the Lord is also warning you if
you are a Christian and you are born of
the spirit but you choose to rebel
against the spirit and you choose to
grieve the spirit and sin and you know
you're in willful sin and you don't
repent then what the spirit will do in
order to allow you to be discipline is
remove his presence to allow demons to
come and torment you and oppress you in
order to drive you to your knees and
repentance that's 1 Corinthians chapter
5: 1-5 is that also what David fears in
Psalm 51 when he say beg not to remove
the spirit from him yeah that's Psalm
5111 because without the Holy Spirit
you're devoid of life without the Holy
Spirit you are powerless and weak this
is why in 1 Corinthians 5 verses 1 and5
there's a warning Paul says there's an
immoral brother who's having sex with a
stepmother and then he tells the church
I've already passed judgment in the
spirit because we're all born of one
spirit and if we have one Spirit we come
to the same conclusion and pass the same
judgment I've already passed judgment on
if he doesn't repent throw him out of
the church disfellowship him hand him
over to Satan for destruction of his
flesh so that is spirit will be saved on
the day of the Lord so if you are a
Believer but you're in willful sin
unrepentant sin what the spirit will do
is hand you over to being demonically
oppressed so that Satan can unleash hell
on you to torment you to show you you
are powerless without the spirit so that
you can cry out to the Lord
and be restored but you cannot be empty